hey guys this is uh phillip
i'm originally from germany um i live in
las vegas now for a year
i was in the relationship when the
pandemic started and
broke things up a couple of weeks ago
and one of the things that bothered me
in the relationship really was
alcohol involved and for you rich with
the experiences you have made
i i have a question how are you actually
dealing
with people in your surroundings and
people in your environment
that have not a real addiction where
they
get hooked up on alcohol or things like
every single day
but more even you know
oh let's have a glass of wine and then
one glass turns into two or three
and it happens like once a week how do
you handle
um people like that uh yeah keep up the
good work and
talk to you soon thanks for your
question phillip uh i suspect that
this is probably a more prevalent issue
living in a place like las vegas that
would be maybe in other locations um
i'm empathetic to the predicament but i
would say for me it's kind of a
double-edged
situation because on the one hand
you know i've been sober for a long time
and i'm really just never around
people like that anymore it's just not
part of my
inner social circle like it once was
but if in when i am around
that kind of scenario it doesn't really
bother me
that much because my sobriety is strong
it's not like i'm triggered by it i can
be around people that are
drinking a couple glasses of wine and it
it doesn't really
affect me in any meaningful way like if
it starts getting crazy and people are
getting hammered and stuff like that
i'll just leave because it's boring for
me
right but it's not like i feel
threatened or anything like that
um and the reason i'm not around
people like that very much is that i
just don't i don't seek out those people
or those
experiences anymore like i used to um
but when i and when i when i do
encounter them i i'm pretty capable of
managing it without
incidents um it doesn't affect your
energy
no it doesn't affect my energy so so one
question i guess i would have
up front that i'm curious about is is
why
philip it's so bothersome for you
because you're talking about people who
have maybe two or three glasses of wine
once a week
which is a pretty for a lot of people
like that's a pretty
normal thing it's not that out of
control so what is it inside of you
that's getting activated by that and if
it's just that you don't want to have
that
in your environment then that's cool
but that just means that just means
you're going to have to expand your
social circle and find
other types of people to hang out with
or you know
involve yourself in in like get out to
the red rocks or just get you know
go to places where it's a different type
of
cultural cohesion where drinking really
isn't so front and center
in terms of how you're interacting
socially
personally i'm just not in the business
of of taking anyone else's
inventory so i don't sit in judgment of
somebody who wants to have two or three
glasses of wine
but and i would say this to you like we
do have choices as to who we spend
our time with and i think in my
experience the best way of managing
this kind of situation if you're just
not enthusiastic about
being with people who are into that
right now you don't have to make a big
statement
about it or a manifesto about how you're
not going to stand for this anymore
you could just back away slowly from
that environment right and i think of it
in terms of
concentric rings of intimacy so if you
think of yourself in the middle
and then there's a bunch of circles
outside of you that expand
who is in that inner ring and those
would be the people that you trust the
most you trust implicitly
then the next ring of people would be
people who maybe are just more casual
friends and it kind of
goes out from there so i'm constantly
thinking about the people that i keep in
that inner circle
and then the people who get moved to
outer rings because something else
happens and
you have the ability to slowly
transition your social time
to more like-minded people who are
aligned with your social habits
and you can move those you know you can
move away from those people or those
people just get
kind of slowly pushed out to a different
range it doesn't mean that you can't be
friends with them anymore
it's just that the dynamic of your
friendship might get tweaked a little
bit
and it doesn't have to be that big a
deal and i would also
say that it's important you know on the
subject of not taking anyone's inventory
or making a big deal in terms of how
you pro cl you don't have to proclaim
this to anybody
i think it's important to have
compassion for the fact that it's been a
[ __ ] hard year for a lot of people
and certain people are going to be like
i want to have two or three glasses of
wine and if they can do that and they're
happy with their life
that's their business it's not mine to
judge
so i tend to err on on giving people a
break and giving people
some latitude and understanding that we
all have different ways of
coping with the various anxieties and
stressors that that we face
but ultimately this is about your
relationship with you
and i think it's incumbent upon you to
stop focusing on what others are doing
or being upset because people aren't
behaving in a manner that you would
prefer them to behave
want you know stop grinding on why they
aren't doing doing things your way
and just focus more on on your path and
your choices and the people that you
choose to
spend time with
[Music]
you